toxic mud flats killing rivers and
forests poisonous clouds drifting across
borders at a conference in the European
Parliament it was debated how an n can
be put to impunity that until now has
been the rule for perpetrators of such
crimes the UM velvet velvet suit or does
Kip Keino zhuangjian the ted kundan
common why does emerged refreshed niched
and VJ Durst on Java and internet soon
and Roth garage so far getting for
brushing a dimension ish guide often we
are high in the Nazi lunch laughter so
fun for brushing getting the home world
Herman Van Rompuy a charm offensive
seems to have worked Mickey's broadly
welcomed the council presidents
initiative to move against tax evasion
and tax havens inside and outside of
Europe saw karate Andrew aivazovsky was
parise rich guys coming atoms into
Thomas TomSka Vikram's cross paths
officiant but it'll still me up in and
share so near douglas on snow our
service there's owners match published a
magical that in our service destinations
are as much competitiveness at a time
where data processing has became
ubiquitous the use rules on data
protection which led from the mid-1990s
are starting to become outdated when
presenting his annual report of the
European Parliament the European data
protection supervisor underlined the
importance of the new framework that is
currently under discussion between EU
institutions the decisions which are
being taken now will be determining our
quality of life quality of our
fundamental rights in the coming 15
years we cannot afford to get it wrong
more than 3,000 amendments have been
laid down for the you data protection
regulation is said to be voted on in the
civil liberties committee before the
summer break